servus skills und herzlich willkommen
von einem parkplatz irgendwo in der nähe
von köln ich werde mich morgen heute ist
noch sonntag in köln karneval feiern
zusammen mit dem blut nein man ist
gerade an der kamera hat max mitgenommen
nach köln und genau warum stehen wir
gerade kannst du mal so dumm sein damit
galt die karre abgestellt und fun fact
das ist es eigentlich heute aufgefallen
dass hier am fenster irgendwas mal gar
nicht stimmt marco ist heute die so
lester der wind so krass reinfeldt auf
der alm 130 auch immer man sie ist ganz
gut so wie youtube wieder auf jeden fall
da müssen wir gucken ob wir das remis
war ein neues community oder zulegen
hab irgendwie sowas von seiner ansage
für so ein rap video hinterher regeln
sollte das halt die fresse diese bei
aggro tv und jetzt hat die ok du scheiße
gelabert wir setzen uns ins auto rein
weiß hier draußen kalt ist und dann
beantworten der fragen die uns gestellt
hat ist er drin ist habe ich gehört geht
es geht es hier auch
ich glaub ja legen wir los fragen vor
allem eins von zumeist einfache username
ist 12 05 11 fragt warum hast du so
schöne haare echter question erstmal
danke ich hab mir die haare
abgeschnitten das war ja nicht sein
deswegen auf die fall ausgewählt ich
habe jetzt wieder so seiten boxer
schnitt hat mir einfach die seiten auf 9
mm schneiden lassen oberhaupt ich immer
noch nicht fest
nichts frage oliver tanzbär vater
christian kommst du zu den video days
danke für deine frage und ja ich bin
natürlich bei der bos wobei natürlich
jetzt noch niemand weiß wie viele video
days es dieses jahr geben wird gefühlt
wenn es immer mehr jedes jahr aber ich
bin auf jeden fall in berlin und köln am
start plätze wie geht will ich versuche
es zu ihr hin zu bekommen die video ist
motivieren immer so das ganze jahr man
sitzen zu hause in seinem keller ist ein
kellerkind wie ich das nicht rausgeht
und den aufruf zeit wenn man einmal den
wgs auf die echten menschen hinter
trifft dann ist das immer sehr
motivierend macht spaß und das ist gut
so machen dass immer wieder leute ich
hab kein apple max und mir ist
aufgefallen dass man das netz einfach
komisch sind total komisch ok julia
schilly celine fragt kommst du mal nach
karlsruhe
ich habe tatsächlich bekannt in
karlsruhe die ich werde demnächst aber
besuchen werde aber im allgemeinen habe
ich mir vorgenommen jetzt immer wenn ich
in irgendeiner größeren deutschen stadt
wien wo eventueller fans sind dass ich
da ein kleines fantreffen mache also
dass ich zumindest wenn ich bock habt
zumindest mal vorab bescheid geben oder
so heute in köln
am montag wird es ziemlich unrealistisch
weil es so krass voll sein wird deswegen
stelle ich mein auto auch die heimischen
der außerhalb ab weil darin wird nur
abgehen
ich versuche mich selbst daran zu
erinnern
triff uns nachts parkplatz park and ride
warum fragst du welche tageszeit
ich bin jedoch nachts heim wieso fragt
welche tageszeit
ich bin all zeit bereit gibbs sagte tat
bereit sie mein mercedes an
es können wird sich erst in der tat
bereit
die kamera hat gerade eben einfach
aufgehört aufzunehmen weil wir zu zweit
bittet haben kennen das gefühl
ja was manchmal raum auch wenn die
kinder auf der welt sind
so kann man kann nicht so leicht über
familie retten deswegen macht es auch
wenn die kinder auf der welt sind ist
klar dass der held in der werden die
kinder auf der welt sind wirklich zu den
piste da vorne
gib mir dein geld sinn heute das ist
eine frage die makler zu beantworten ich
lache ich wusste erst zu beantworten er
ohne rein und zwar data extrakt question
wie stehst du dazu dass manche youtuber
sich quasi selbst verkaufen
jedem das seine oder findest du das zu
blöd ist eine wichtige frage weil ich
persönlich dieser jedem das seine
einstellung nicht glaubt hab ich das
ding okay sind nur weil andere sie auch
machen würden so nach dem motto bin
mittlerweile auch dagegen dass man
youtuber für alles kritisiert was zu
machen oder so aber da die wir sind gern
kurzes beispiel gehen wir mal über das
gebiet der kann man jetzt vielleicht
oder auch baby zu einer leichte
manipulation ihrer zuschauer
unterstellen dann gibt es leute die
sagen das ist okay dass sie quasi ihre
zuschauer manipuliert weil andere das
genauso machen würden und jedem das
seine
genau das glaube ich nämlich nicht ich
glaube es gibt gewisse grundregeln die
man sich zu halten hat ganz ehrlich wo
kommt man hin wenn wir wenn wir sagen
wenn jeder das machen darf worauf er
bock hat worauf dieses jedem das seien
ja quasi hindeutet dann brauchen
eigentlich auch kein gesetz weil jedem
das seine so wenn er ein rocker die mann
umzubringen
ihr müsst eine es gibt schon ein paar
grundwerte wie rücksicht wertschätzung
für andere menschen die man einfach
nicht vergessen darf in so dieses jedem
das seine ist überhaupt nicht mein ding
überhaupt nicht bin ich vollkommen
dagegen ich habe da schon moralische
prinzipien und dagegen sollten nur
sporadische indizien
ok und ich schlafe jetzt hier
2 bgb de